there's not enough good words to say
about twitch just a positive impact he
had on people I was in complete shock
and I think just the sheer sadness of
how this happened really made people
understand worldwide just how fragile
life is and to tell each other you love
each other and to really check in we've
always crossed Paths of twitch and he is
was the nicest guy ever I think anyone
who's ever met twitch will say that he
is the nicest most caring most present
person and and really wants to make
everyone feel better when I first
started dancing it was on So You Think
You Can Dance and he was the poster
child the Pinnacle the guy that never
gave up and just kept going and he made
it on the show and became such a
inspiration of so many dancers including
myself it's just it's so hard to believe
I know a lot of us found out first thing
in the morning and I think it just hit
all of us how precious and how short
life really is Steven twitch was such a
significant part of the dance Community
but then he had this amazing ability to
go way beyond that and he just lit up
every room and he was so positive and no
matter where he was I think obviously as
dancers anytime somebody in the
community goes through something hard we
all feel for them we're just hoping that
people can use this as an opportunity to
reach out to the people that they love
reach out to the people that may be
struggling he was my judge when I did so
you think he can dance and he is like
the reason he stayed sane in a way I
remember after my audition like it's
just the look and as high as like I just
saw like how proud he was and like he
didn't even have to say anything and I
just saw it there was never a moment
where we lost your face I always think
that's one of the illest things that
like the really dope ballroom dancers
dude he literally just like did a
windmill over somebody's body and then
came back down it was like camera he
basically gave me the confidence that I
needed throughout That season I just
thought he was an angel I really did and
I just couldn't believe something like
this would happen to somebody who was
just so good and so pure my heart goes
out to Alison and the kids and to his
whole family and I just can't imagine
what they're going through
foreign
[Music]